memory
i feel like i i listen to a lot about
memory and how
memory is intertwined with karma
memory is karma
karma is memory that's why i said it's a
residual impact
right now what is in your conscious
memory is not even one percent of what
is actually there
see
you definitely don't remember
you being an amoeba do you remember no
but your body remembers
today i'm sorry i have to use such
horrible examples can i yeah it's a bad
example any example let's say
you love cats and then you decided
because they don't like your food you
decided to eat their food out of your
love you know because love means that i
should do what you like sure yeah
exactly all right yeah so you started
eating cat food
in two months time will you turn into a
cat no every cell in your body remembers
that you are a human being this is
called evolutionary memory it will not
forget
every cell in your body thinks why this
dumb idiot is eating cat food
we can do better yes but it will not
turn you into cat cells or cat body all
right because there is evolutionary
memory it will not get confused do what
you want
now
ten generations ago your great great
great grandmother how she looked do you
remember no no
but her nose may be sitting on your face
right now exactly the way it was
a million years ago what was the skin
texture of your forefathers
still on isn't it
so this whole thing what you call as
myself is simply memory this is your
karma
because you have that kind of memory
you tend to automatically act in a
particular way
this is karma
so why we want to be free from karma is
because we don't want to be an extension
of the past we want to be a fresh life
if you want to be a fresh life you must
be able to stand in the richness of your
memory and do your act now
fresh act but
if you sink into this memory then you
will be doing only the past thinking it
is the future
is there any escaping that though of
course
see i
i'm escaped
i'm a yogi means i'm supposed to sit
like this
see
i'm doing everything i can
just to freak them out a little bit
do you have to face the memory
to heal it no no no no
see the in what is there as memory in
this
i'm sorry i'm using such words i know
these are negative words in social
context
this is a bag of memory that you call as
my body
out of this there is a mechanism called
mind which is also memory out of this is
a mechanism called emotion that is also
memory out of this there is energetic
activity that is also memory all of this
is controlled by the type of memory
impressions that you have
evolutionary uh genetic karmic and
variety of other memories this whole
amalgamation of a complex
uh influx of memories which are
happening to you right now as you look
at me as you look at the garden as you
hear things as you hear the birds as you
hear the automobiles memories getting
piled up
otherwise you wouldn't be able to
recognize anything see right now an
automobile is something which has been a
part of you in many ways
now suppose you had no memory of an
automobile you have never seen one you
never heard one
if i start an automobile it was
then you'll think what is it
once you have heard it and you know it's
an automobile after 10 years if you hear
it you know this is an automobile
how only by previous imprint isn't it
these imprints are far more complex than
you understand
it goes back to an amoeba
all that memory is here
now you don't try to decipher that
because if you try to decipher that
you'll get buried in that memory the
simple thing is
make it uh create enough surface tension
so that it doesn't pop at you all the
time and now it's your stage
if you have a lot of memory
phenomenal amount of memory
there is no such thing as good memory
and bad memory they're just memory
memory means it is past impressions
yesterday can neither be good nor bad
isn't it now
it's over right it cannot be good it
cannot be bad but if you just get
entangled with your memory yesterday can
be bad yesterday can be good right a
whole lot of time most people are living
like this they are not suffering their
life they are suffering their memory
isn't it you said that suffering is
being stuck
in a memory you can't escape can't get
over no right no no i didn't say the
last you didn't say that i didn't say it
in your words please see people are
suffering what happened
10 years ago
what happened 10 years ago does it exist
right now no it's nowhere here
it's only in your memory
so you're suffering this
what is memory what is human memory
compared to the memory of every other
creature on the planet
our memory is far more vivid
than anybody else's memory on this
planet as human beings
this vividness of memory it what gives
us richness of life
because we grasp see right now if i look
at your face i am grasping many aspects
of it which a dog may not grasp a catman
or grass but grasshopper may not grasp
but as a human eye and human
neurological process i am grasping
various aspects of just one face on the
planet the detail that i am grasping
nobody else grasped except a human being
if you have enough attention
you grasp much more
because of this ability to grasp and
perceive things we have a massive sense
of memory
vivid sense of memory now this vivid
sense of memory is what sets us apart
from every other creature the richness
of life and that's what people are
suffering
because
they do not know how to handle their own
memory and their own imagination
if they had let's say yesterday a thorn
went into their
foot
now everywhere they're thinking every
blade of grass is thorn
bad memory or
or somebody is a lala
they think they're walking on flowers
all the time there are people like that
in california because they're on some
they're on something else not on
gasoline
in california